we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's five o'clock you're watching
johnson resigns a newshour special live
from downing street i'm mark austin
coming up in the next 60 minutes
a polarizing prime minister right to the
end the pugnacious boris johnson finally
admits
it's over
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister his wife daughter loyal aides
and mps watching he applauds his
achievements and addresses his
supporters
i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world but them's the
brakes
[Applause]
so boris johnson will go but he says not
yet pledging to wait until a successor
is chosen
the next leader might not be in position
till august and the opposition say
they'll look to force the prime minister
out if he doesn't go sooner
if they don't get rid of him then labour
will step up in the national interest
and bring a vote of no confidence
because we can't go on with this prime
minister clinging on for months and
months to come
and the impact and legacy as politician
and prime minister from that red bus
get brexit done campaigning
[Music]
good evening then from downing street
the scene today of a political drama
that will live long in the memory boris
johnson has resigned but he hasn't gone
in office but now a lame duck a prime
minister seeing out the dying days of
his premiership still surrounded by
controversy at dawn he was still
desperately trying to cling to power but
a torrent of further resignations from
ministers put paid to that and this
evening the jockeying to replace him has
begun and there are plenty who seem to
fancy their chances on top of all this
mr johnson is also trying to put back
together his collapsed government
tonight in this special program we'll
hear from our unparalleled political
team about this historic day what comes
next and the consequences for the
country
i've been here in downing street for
much of the past 48 hours watching these
most extraordinary events unfold and for
now boris johnson is still in number 10.
i'm inside parliament where conservative
mps have to work out whether to oust
boris johnson earlier than he wants to
go and the first candidate to succeed
him as prime minister for starting to
declare
i'll be examining the economic
challenges the new leader will face and
what boris johnson might try to do
before he leaves office
and i'm live in one of the towns that
propelled boris johnson to power powell
has his departure gone down here
all of that to come but first our
political editor beth rigby reports now
on the day boris johnson finally
admitted
his time was up
out of number 10 and out of his job good
afternoon everybody
hard to believe for him and this
dwindling bunch of die hard johnson
backers comforting each other as after
days of defiance the prime minister
finally relents
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and the timetable will be
announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
his wife carrie with their
nine-month-old daughter watched on
alongside number 10 staff as boris
johnson told the country he hadn't
wanted to go and in the last few days
i've tried to persuade my colleagues
that it would be eccentric to change
governments when we're delivering so
much i regret and not to have been
successful in those arguments and of
course it's painful and not to be able
to see through so many ideas and
projects myself but as we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves
acknowledging he couldn't carry on but
true to himself to the very end
no remorse here
there was though regret
i know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and uh perhaps quite a few who will also
be disappointed
and i want you to know how sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the breaks
even if things can sometimes
seem dark now
our future
together
is golden
and this is why he had to go the
avalanche of resignation letters
triggered by cabinet ministers sajid
javid and rishi sunak's resignations
that in the end buried boris johnson his
time really up when his new chancellor
nadim zahawi publicly called for the
prime minister to go and staunch allies
call in time to
i'm just sad that it came to this
because i think he is a good person
instinctively and i think that he could
have been and should have been a great
prime minister but sadly just some poor
choices
over too long a time it just meant his
position was untenable but with this
place engulfed in drama the business of
running the country goes on boris
johnson says he'll stay on until a
successor can be found but many
conservative mps want him to leave now
and another caretaker pm to come in the
last 48 hours his refusal to accept
reality has done a lot of damage um to
trust in the institution as a whole in
in parliament in in the conventions that
we have in the conservative party that
when the game's up the game's up and
unfortunately it took a long time for
the prime minister to realize that but
number 10 not the only place across
westminster with vacancies boris johnson
today rapidly filling ministerial posts
including within his cabinet in a bid to
keep this show on the road labour
demanding an immediate overhaul they've
declared him unfit to be prime minister
they can't inflict him on the country
for the next few months if they don't
get rid of him we will bring that vote
to no confidence
in the national interest because we
can't go on with this broken government
led by this discredited prime minister
boris johnson will always be remembered
as the politician that brought brexit to
great britain
at his height he was the most successful
conservative party leader at the ballot
box since the days of margaret thatcher
he won a huge mandate and had it in his
gift to lead this country for a decade
or more
that was the plan but it didn't turn out
like that instead he finds himself
leaving office and as one of the
shortest serving prime ministers in the
history of his country a man who in the
end let his party and his people down a
politician who is as talented and
charismatic as he is flawed and
destructive in the end it was boris
johnson who brought himself down
thank you all very much
a dramatic end to a dramatic premiership
a politician as defiant in giving up
power as he was in taking it he will
always be remembered if not always for
the right reasons
and beth we've seen some resignations in
this street but none
quite as extraordinary as this one
not quite like that i mean what an
extraordinary 48 hours my mind's still
spinning actually as i go through the
events and try to process what has just
happened and as i was saying in that
report if you zoom out and think what is
going on this was a politician that was
potentially going to be in power for a
decade or more he won a huge mandate he
had it in his gift to redraw this
country push through really bold policy
and instead he became fast caught in the
coveted pandemic well that was clearly
beyond his control and then he got
caught in a series of his own scandals
his own missteps that brought him down
and it really is a sort of tragic story
of someone that is brilliant in many
ways as a politician
never have i known a politician so
determined or ruthless actually as boris
johnson but also a man who is deeply
flawed and some of those character flaws
and
sort of areas of conduct in the end were
the things that did for him not the
policies but the character and some of
the politics of how he tried to run that
place and it really is astonishing he'll
go down as one of the shortest serving
prime ministers this country has ever
seen when he won one of the biggest
mandates we'd seen for years and years
and years not since tony blair had
anyone won a mandate like that and so uh
it really is a
story of a unfulfilled potential and it
is an extraordinary day in another sense
i mean politically he's had a cabinet
meeting he has and you've got some
details i have i've actually just been
given or sent the readout of this
cabinet minister meeting now this was
interesting because a lot of mps were
very angry that he was even reconvening
a cabinet many think he should still go
i spoke to robert buckland who is the
new welsh secretary shortly before this
cabinet and he made it clear that boris
johnson in his view was an administrator
now not a leader so he's going to run
government but he wasn't going to take
decisions and that's clearly been the
terms of engagement that the cabinet
have now set uh in the readout it says
here boris johnson made clear the
government would not seek to implement
new policies or make major changes of
direction rather it would focus on
delivering the agenda on which the
government was elected the prime
minister said major fiscal decisions
should be left for the next prime
minister that's critical mark because
that was all about whether having lost
rishi sanak he would then try and put in
tax cuts and and make fiscal decisions
what is clear there is he is still in
there but this is a holding position and
a cabinet now that has asserted itself
over a completely uh done prime minister
and he is not going to be able to to do
what he wants and maybe they are also
doing that in order to try and placate a
party many of whom don't want him in
there a moment longer and would like him
to leave now no which is deeply divided
yeah beth thank you very much indeed uh
let's just take a closer look now at the
uh how the process to replace boris
johnson will operate as things stand the
prime minister can approach the queen at
any time to request that she appoints
someone else's interim leader but at the
moment boris johnson as we've been
hearing is staying as a caretaker prime
minister until a new one is chosen to
take part in the race a conservative mp
needs to be nominated by eight
colleagues then all conservative mps
vote in a series of rounds whittling the
list of candidates down the person who
receives the fewest votes is eliminated
after every round voting continues until
two candidates remain then
party members get to make their final
choice before a deadline set by the 1922
committee of conservative backed
benchers and then a new prime minister
is installed it's thought the current
plan is for this to happen by the time
the conservative party conference starts
and that is on
october the 2nd
so who are the likely candidates to
replace boris johnson
as prime minister well there are quite a
few both the former chancellor rishi
sunak
uh as well as the foreign secretary liz
truss have both at times been favourites
to succeed mr johnson also among those
presumed to be in the running are the
former health secretary
sajid javid also jeremy hunt
who's currently
chair of the health and social care
committee last night the attorney
general sue ella braverman announced
that she would run
to become leader also in the frame so it
goes on would be the current chancellor
and former education secretary nadim
zahawi but the leading candidate at the
moment appears to be the defense
secretary ben wallace who is the most
popular cabinet minister among
conservative party members
and also
in public polls
well one name not on that list as far as
i know but two has served alongside all
of them is the environment secretary
george eustis thanks very much indeed
for being with us now i'm not sure
whether in the end you joined the push
for him to go but do you accept
that his time was up
yes because under our system prime
ministers can only remain in post if
they've got the overall confidence of
parliament and that in practice means
having uh the confidence of the vast
majority of your own parliamentary party
and i think after that confidence vote
in early june when 148 conservative mps
voted against him he was in a very
difficult position he had a short window
when uh you know he had a chance to try
and turn it around but ultimately you
know he hasn't been able to do that and
so i think he he made the right decision
uh today to stand down it's it's the
right thing to do i think when prime
ministers get to that position they've
lost confidence it's the only thing
really available to them
and do you think he made the right
decision by staying on many mps are
unhappy that he hasn't simply gone and
handed over to a caretaker prime
minister
no i think absolutely he's right he he
will now be that caretaker prime
minister that's what theresa may did
that's what david cameron did it's what
uh tony blair did it's what happens in
these situations um the last thing you
want is to chop and change and have
somebody else come in as a temporary
prime minister for six weeks or two
months and then change again that makes
no sense at all you want a degree of
continuity but obviously the approach of
this government is to make sure that key
decisions can be made that we continue
to do our bit to support the ukraine
that we continue to make timely
decisions to to help the nhs as it comes
out of the pandemic
and some of those economic decisions
which are also you know important so
it's to make sure that we've got a
functioning government in place but
there's no doubt in my mind that the
prime minister's the right one to to see
that through and it just makes no sense
to try and have somebody else
but that's all well and good but if you
can't command the confidence of the
house of commons should you still be in
downing street
uh yes because that's uh what happens
when theresa may lost the confidence of
the party she still
did her her bit for public service and
saw out that term as prime minister
that's what boris johnson will do as
well and i think here look the reality
is
the prime minister's now decided to to
go very quickly the media establishment
people like you and indeed the
conservative parliamentary party
are going to get very focused on the
leadership contest who they want to be
the next leader um things will soon move
on and the last thing they want to be
worrying about is what happens uh in
these last two months the attention will
move to other more important things
so on that subject i mean who do you
think will take over it seems
uh we saw the list there everyone in his
dog is standing
well um all sorts of things can happen
obviously in a uh leadership contest i
think the party having been through you
know quite a bruising period we'll want
to try and choose someone who can unite
the party and pull it back together and
get it on a clear mission to to deal
with some of the challenges we've got
between now and the general election so
i think um that'll be what they're
trying to do but look i i've worked on a
couple of leadership campaigns one for
david cameron and for michael gove
actually last time round and i know that
they're very volatile all sorts of
things can happen you get unexpected
things
and it'll happen quite quickly you know
within the next two weeks we're probably
going to see
i suspect quite a wide list of
candidates narrowed down to the final
two
yeah which campaign do you think you'll
be working on this time around george
um i i don't know i've done a couple of
them they're quite uh draining uh
exhausting things i'm still in the
government so i've got a job to do uh
there but i shall obviously wait and see
who puts a hat in the ring who comes
forward and see what they've got to say
before i uh make any sort of decision so
i haven't really if i might have turned
my attention to it at the moment i know
uh there are runners and riders out
there people have already made it known
that they intend to stand and obviously
i'll be considering that along with
every other mp over the next week or so
uh just a minute to left judging by his
speech it seemed to me that he
he felt betrayed you know talking about
this sort of heard instinct of the tory
party is that the way you saw it
well i think as i say the the truth here
is that uh he had lost the the
confidence of of parliament and a
significant
number of our own mps and you know then
it's the reality is his position was
untenable at that time but look i i uh
you know feel some sadness here and and
i i think it's been a very bruising time
for those who've supported the prime
minister and worked with him
in number 10 over these last very
difficult days
i always have sympathy for teams who
have to sort of find themselves in this
position i've been there myself as an
advisor previously and i i it's never
it's never easy when a prime minister
goes uh very few of them get to go on
their own terms
even people like tony blair who tried to
ended up chasing out the door by his own
party
it's just not easy margaret thatcher's
wasn't easy david cameron was taken by
surprise by that referendum result uh
they they very go well on their own
terms i'm afraid and that's just
one of the features of that job
and finally he squandered this huge
majority very quickly two and a half
years how will he be remembered as prime
minister do you think
well i hope he'd be remembered not by
the the length of his tenure but what he
achieved in that time and he had
obviously an enormous amount of uh
problems thrown his way uh dealing with
the pandemic and all of the aftermath of
that but i think he'll be um remembered
as uh as a as a prime minister who who
showed um boldness uh when it needed to
be shown in order to break a
long-standing brexit deadlock get brexit
delivered finally deliver that
referendum result which we've argued
about for four years that'll be his uh
legacy and what he's remembered for most
george eustis appreciate your time
thanks very much thank you
well boris johnson came to power just
under three years ago with a promise to
get brexit done he then secured a
landslide victory in 2019's general
election on a wave of public support but
his time in office was soon
characterized by controversy over
renovations to his flat his handling of
the covid pandemic and of course over
partygate our home editor jason farrell
reflects on boris johnson's time as
prime minister
are we ready
are we ready
the biggest character in modern british
politics
he was confronted with one of the
deadliest challenges ever faced by any
prime minister covid19
but was the downfall of this great
showman that he simply couldn't survive
being seen for who he really was
a liar a showman
a buffoon
a rank incompetent
and probably
the most shameful prime minister that
britain has ever had and somebody the
like of whom i pray we will never see
again i've always liked boris johnson
he's got a real earnest concern for the
british people and they feel it and it's
because they feel it that they love him
so much
well what a tragedy that we've come to
this but we've come to this by his own
hand i'm sorry to say in a way this will
be as always a personal tragedy you know
that the very
many of the factors that brought boris
johnson to be prime minister are also
responsible for his fall
johnson set out in life to be a winner
as a child his stated ambition was world
king and his method self-belief even if
not everything he said was true
as a journalist he was sacked from the
times to misrepresent misrepresentation
and in politics was sacked again from
his first front bench role for lying
about an affair
but with celebrity appeal and a radar
for popular policy he became london's
first conservative mayor dubbed the
heineken politician reaching parts other
tories couldn't thank you for sticking
up for london and for the innocent
hard-working people of this city
so why not reach number 10.
whether he believed in brexit or not
joining vote leave provided a platform
and a policy that appealed to many
grassroots tories and while theresa may
had first stab at delivering brexit
boris johnson is elected as the leader
of the conservative and unionist party
he convinced the tories and then the
electorate that his so-called oven-ready
deal was better
i think that his strengths
really lay in campaigning i think had he
picked a
particularly strong team around him
and enabled himself to do more of the
campaigning while others did more of the
governing i think he might still be in
place
his rise had been on the sale of
optimism so his initial approach to the
pandemic was the same i was at a
hospital the other night where i think
there were a few there were actually a
few coronavirus patients and i shook
hands with everybody you'll be pleased
to know accused of being slow to lock
down he succumbed to the virus
meanwhile his controversial advisor
dominic cummings broke the rules then
his apparent rivalry with the prime
minister's new bride carrie johnson led
to him being cut loose instantly
becoming his former boss's fiercest
critic
tens of thousands of people died who
didn't need to die but johnson had got
brexit done albeit with stored-up
problems in northern ireland
his next success was on the vaccine
rollout it was world beating far faster
than the eu he'd won an 80-seat majority
and he'd been quick to support ukraine
against aggression from russia and for
those reasons supporters forgave his
failings for as long as they could his
initial support for owen patterson who
was guilty of lobbying while accepting
cash the donor funded refurbishment of
his flat above number 11 the number 10
parties during lockdown and the
inconsistencies over what the prime
minister knew nobody said to me this is
an event that is against the rules
still a police investigation fined him
for breaching his own laws he thought he
could play it all as he has all his life
ever since he was a school boy
at eaton he thought he could do it his
own way and he found out and and
many many people said from the very
beginning uh that it would go wrong the
question was only when
when deputy chief whip chris pincher
stood down after allegations of sexual
harassment it emerged the pm had been
warned of previous behavior
he denied knowing then when it was clear
he did said he'd forgotten
his chancellor and health secretary had
had enough and set in chain a crumbling
of his support i think he will be
remembered as a great communicator um
you know you know the man that he'd
absolutely delivered brexit but i think
he will also remember somebody that that
fundamentally didn't listen the man who
could reach the parts others couldn't
was plunging to the depths pulling his
party with him
it took a damagingly long time for them
and him
to let go
jason farrell sky news
well let's just uh get a sense then of
the mood inside parliament among mps and
peers let's go live to central lobby
inside the houses of parliament now
deputy political editor sam coates good
evening sam so what about this row about
whether boris johnson should go
immediately and not stick around
frankly mark there is a good deal of
unease amongst conservative mps about
where we've ended up tonight just in the
last 72 hours more than 130 tories have
said boris johnson isn't fit for office
yet today at the end of the day where
he's resigned it's clear he's also
looking like he's going to hang around
for weeks if not months as prime
minister now at this point where we have
a war in ukraine there's unprecedented
pressure on people's pocketbooks rising
prices and all of the other
post-pandemic challenges that this
country have we still have boris johnson
in power sitting around the cabinet
table now he has today promised that his
government until he hands over to a
successor isn't going to make embark on
any major changes of course he's not
going to do anything he suggests it's
going to surprise people new policy
but mark the problem for conservative
mps is that only this morning some of
those around boris johnson were looking
at plans for big tax cuts that would be
a radical departure from where the last
chance larissa sunat wanted to take
things uh you've got some members around
the cabinet table who are
sizing up leadership beds they could use
their ongoing cabinet position uh to try
and eke out some uh advantage uh and
you've just got this situation where
nobody is quite sure where a cabinet
that can't take big bold decisions in
the face of all of those pressures are
going to end up so somehow these some
people including former prime minister
john major still wanting boris johnson
to stand down immediately i suspect at
the moment tonight there isn't quite the
mood inside the conservative party to
make that happen they want to see how
the new cabinet beds down but what i do
think is happening is they're discussing
shortening the timetable for the
conservative leadership contest to find
a successor to boris johnson there's a
big desire amongst tory mps to have
worked out who the final two candidates
are by the end of term that's july the
21st are under three weeks time and then
you can send those two names to the part
to the conservative party members in the
country uh to to choose who should be
the next conservative party leader and
heads prime minister getting a new
candidate uh installed in number 10 by
right at the start of september tory
mp's hoping that that is quick enough to
stop boris johnson who promises not to
do any more damage and make sure he
doesn't give enough time to actually
fulfill that promise
right and sam we've been talking about
the contenders we've seen the list uh
what are mps that
you've been talking to what have they
been saying about who the favorites are
well there's a head spinningly large
array of candidates for the uh upcoming
conservative leadership uh contest and i
think what's important and what tory mps
say to me is that this is a critical
juncture a fork in the road moment
because they cover the entire spectrum
ideological spectrum of the conservative
party and if you get somebody perhaps
from the left of the party maybe
somebody like tom tugan hat who's
already declared and a number of tory
mps have told me today they're backing
him then that will take the party and
the country in a totally different
direction than somebody from the right
like sowella braverman who's also made
it uh clear she intends to run will
there be confrontation with europe will
there be uh tax cuts funded by borrowing
big big choices are at stake in the
contest that's going to happen over the
next six weeks conservative party
ideology on the border streets was all
over the place and it was quite clear
the direction the party and this
leadership contest could set it in a
certain course but nobody knows what
that course is yet
okay sam thank you very much indeed
well the confirmation that boris johnson
had finally accepted his time in downing
street was coming to an end came just
after midday a lectin was brought out
into the street behind me here members
of the downing street staff mps and the
prime minister's wife and baby daughter
stood waiting and then boris johnson
emerged here is his resignation speech
in full
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister and i've agreed with segren
brady the chairman of our backbench mps
that the process of choosing that new
leader should begin now and the
timetable will be announced next week
and i've today appointed a cabinet to
serve as i will until a new leader is in
place
so i want to say to the millions of
people who voted for us in 2019 many of
them voting conservative for the first
time
thank you
for that incredible mandate the biggest
conservative majority since 1987
the biggest share of the vote
since 1979
the reason i have fought so hard in the
last few days to continue to deliver
that mandate in person
was not just because i wanted to do so
but because i felt it was
my job
my duty
my obligation to you to continue to do
what we promised in 2019
and of course i'm immensely proud of the
achievements of this government from
getting brexit done to settling our
relations with the continent for over
half a century
reclaiming
the power for this country to make its
own laws in parliament getting us all
through the pandemic delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe the
fastest exit from lockdown
and
in the last few months leading the west
in standing up to putin's aggression in
ukraine
and let me say now to the people of
ukraine that i know that we in the uk
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes
and
at the same time in this country we've
been pushing forward a vast program of
investment in infrastructure and skills
and technology the biggest
in a century
because if i have one insight into human
beings it is that genius and talent and
enthusiasm and imagination
are evenly distributed throughout the
population but opportunity is not and
that's why we must keep leveling up keep
unleashing the potential of every part
of the united kingdom
and if we
can do that in this country we will be
the most prosperous in europe
and in the last few days i've tried to
persuade my colleagues that it would be
eccentric to change governments when
we're delivering so much and when we
have such a vast mandate and when we're
actually only a handful of points behind
in the polls even in mid-term after
quite a few months of pretty relentless
sledging and when
the economic scene is so difficult
domestically and internationally and i
regret and not to have been successful
in those arguments and of course it's
painful and not to be able to see
through so many ideas and projects
myself but as we've seen
at westminster
the herd instinct is powerful when the
herd moves it moves
and my friends in politics no one is
remotely indispensable and our brilliant
and darwinian system will produce
another leader
equally committed to taking this country
forward through tough times
not just helping families to get through
it but changing and improving the way we
do things cutting burdens on businesses
and families and yes cutting taxes
because that is the way to generate the
growth and the income we need to pay for
great public services
and to that new leader i say whoever he
or she may be i say i will give you as
much support as i can
and to you
the british public
i know that there will be many people
who are relieved
and
perhaps quite a few who will also be
disappointed and i want you to know how
sad i am
to be giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the breaks
i want to thank carrie and our children
and all the members of my family who
have had to put up with so much for so
long
i want to thank the peerless british
civil service for all the help and
support that you have given our police
our emergency services and of course our
fantastic nhs who at critical moment
helped to extend my own period in office
as well as our armed services and our
agencies that are so admired around the
world
and are interfatible conservative party
members and supporters whose selfless
campaigning makes our democracy possible
i want to thank the wonderful staff here
at checkers
to here at number 10 and of course at
checkers and our fantastic prop force
detectives
the one group by the way
who never leak
above all
i want to thank
you the british public
for the immense privilege that you have
given me
and i want you to know
that from now on until the new prime
minister is in place
your interests
will be served
and the government of the country
will be carried on
being prime minister
is an education in itself
i've traveled to every part of the
united kingdom
and in addition to the beauty of our
natural world
i found so many people
possessed
of such boundless british originality
and so willing to tackle old problems in
new ways
that i know that even if things can
sometimes
seem dark now
our future
together
is golden
thank you all very much
thank you
there we are an historic moment boris
johnson speaking right here a little
earlier today let's get a sense of how
that resignation is being received in
constituencies which turned to the
conservatives at the last election after
decades of supporting labor the
so-called red wall let's go live to
bolton and uh chief north of england
correspondent greg milam
greg
yeah mark um the prime minister's case
of course was that it shouldn't have
been mps and members of the cabinet
deciding his fate
but those voters who turned out for him
in in 2019 that he was accountable to
them and it was in places like this you
mentioned that red wall a seat like this
one that had been held by labor since
1997 but in 2019 did turn uh
conservative blue albeit with a pretty
narrow majority and we can get some
reaction from some of those who voted
for the conservatives back then dave was
the landlord of the sportsman very
kindly welcomed us in uh this evening
you you were a boris fan then you're
still a boris fan now what was your
reaction to what happened to today i
just think it's disgraceful that the man
that we voted in the conservative voices
in the north of england voted in the red
wall voted in
um lots of first-time voters uh lots of
people who normally voted labor
and uh and now it's been taken away from
us whether or wrongly but the general
public haven't had the chance to have
their say and say what how they feel we
knew what we were getting when we voted
for boris we do he invents silly
mistakes and says things that he doesn't
mean and has his jokes we knew that when
we elected him
he's been taken away from us by a
relentless media campaign
but even your local mp the conservative
mp resigned in the last 24 hours because
he had enough
yes he did but um it's like i said uh
earlier um
when the mp starts to switch they all
seem to jump on the same ship um they
all leave as one and um
my opinion is that that they should have
stood by him they should have stopped by
boris because he's the man who got them
elected lots of these um conservative
mps with very slight majorities probably
won't get voted in again
and i think it's an on goal i think they
said they couldn't trust him i mean can
you can you say that you still trust him
as a person
it's what we voted for we knew what
we're getting we knew what we're getting
and the big decisions he's got every big
decision right we were the first out of
lockdown we put the first for the
vaccines it was good it was great to
record he's been great with the ukraine
situation
the big decisions he's got right okay
he's been a few step ups with his
comments his jaw it's his joke in nature
we all knew he was like that that is why
we voted him that's why the average man
in the street voted for him well you
mentioned covert and mark's next to you
and and like like the prime minister
ended up in in intensive care with cody
you voted for him what's your feeling
today
i think that it's a great shame the
mother in which things have taken place
i think that a person who can have such
foresight as he had to be
basically stabbed in the back i think is
a disgrace i like asked david could you
with with the parties and with what's
happened recently with a an mp accused
of serious sexual assault and he was he
didn't take action on that could you
still trust him after all of those you
turn around say um
serious sexual assault and yet nothing
was done about it i would turn around
and say that uh
until it's actually proved those kind of
things are not the things that really
should be being talked about at this
particular time and and also with us um
on the other side of the table high-end
what was it i mean so much talk about
the red wall and the conservatives
winning in places like this what was it
about boris johnson what is it about
boris johnson that still persuades
people
he's young
he's got foresight
he actually stood for what we believed
in
and he went at it with force
he was a good man and still is a good
man yes he's made mistakes we all make
mistakes huge mistakes even
all this about partygate and all the
rest of it is just nonsense it's all
piped up just start getting him out
and it's wrong
and thanks thanks to all of you that's
that's the view here as boris johnson
said it should have been for those
voters to make the decision but as we
know from today it wasn't much to the
disappointment of certainly the the
people we're talking to here
yeah
okay greg thank you very much so what
will boris johnson's political legacy
we're joined by the contemporary
historian sir anthony selden good to see
you anthony thank you very much for
being
on the program i mean it was a in a way
a humiliating end for
boris johnson but where will he sit do
you think in the pantheon of prime
ministers
uh very humiliating uh for him mark he
is a man of of dignity
and uh the way that it all ended uh will
have hurt him but equally he did bring
that on himself
uh other prime ministers uh earlier
there have been 54 before him
uh when caught in that same predicament
where they were losing support from
their back benches and from their
cabinet
they uh like margaret thatcher uh
thought well that's uh enough enough is
enough i'm off i'm not going to
uh be dragged through uh the sewers
of exactly what's happened now
historically unprecedented numbers of
resignations eventually forcing him out
so that's going to be important in
assessing him in history the way that he
chose to go he chose not to go with
dignity not to go uh with control uh but
uh evidently forced out
uh and mark he was there at historic
moments he did win a
landslide election victory the first for
the conservatives for 32 years he did
get brexit done even if he didn't uh
make the benefits of brexit apparent uh
he did oversee the country through covid
and he did
steer
a leadership course with ukraine um but
he also didn't do a lot he didn't uh uh
make leveling up happen his domestic
agenda
uh is um
is remarkably thin he leaves the economy
and cost of living in a perilous state
sure a lot of that is because of uh
covered uh but it's a very mixed uh
premiership is what i'm suggesting and
overhanging it all and uh infusing every
part of it um uh is the question of his
moral
character
and judgment but also his suitability i
mean great at the big picture great at
communication um but not good at detail
uh or thinking things through thinking
through logically if i do this then how
am i gonna deal with that he would
sooner not have known about that so he
leaves a lot of issues for his successor
to pick up including what is going to be
as we heard on those interviews there is
going to be a very divided party
i mean was it a risk for the
conservative party to make him uh prime
minister after all they knew
surely the sort of character they were
getting
i would say that he's turned out exactly
as those who know him uh uh would have
predicted that they knew that they were
getting somebody who makes people feel
good who exudes optimism who's funny
uh can make great speeches uh can see
our historic pictures and a very good
empathetic sense
as we saw often during covid um not
least with his own catching uh covid and
nearly dying he does have a real gift at
communication and also a visionary gift
he was right up there on the environment
again that's a shame that he didn't one
of many things that he didn't carry
through he gave great leadership uh in
the g7 uh to global leaders and up at uh
glasgow behind the scenes on cop26 so a
legacy of starting many things but not
seeing them through
[Music]
a shame
yeah and what do you think it is about
his character anthony that you know
allows him
to do what he did playing fast and loose
with the truth if you like and these
issues of integrity what is it about him
well it goes back to that earlier
question mark those who knew it well are
totally unsurprised that he has turned
out to be the prime minister that he has
uh it was a formula that worked for him
at eastern and at oxford and it worked
when he was uh in brussels and the
telegraph and editing the spectator it
worked quite well for him when he was
mayor of london but that style that that
flip-flop style
and glossing over the detail and making
light of everything does not work in the
most important uh office in the country
where real gravitas uh is there so it
was evident from the very beginning that
he just is too flippant uh he doesn't
take issues seriously enough it doesn't
go deep enough with him northern ireland
was a particularly glaring example where
he needed uh real emotional intelligence
to to get it which he never did um
so i i think all those keys were there
uh but he was at his most effective uh
in his first year when he uh got brexit
done won the general election victory uh
and uh early on with kovid uh he he did
a lot i mean say this is a
unquestionably uh historic uh one of the
more historic
premierships that we've had in this
country in terms of uh what he achieved
great prime ministers are made by great
events rather than uh vice versa but
also a deeply deeply flawed uh premier
and leader so history will say i think
all these things
okay uh so anthony selden uh appreciate
your time thank you for coming on
ashley thank you for having me
well the political crisis at the heart
of government comes against the backdrop
of the biggest cost of living crisis in
a generation today the office of budget
responsibility warned that the public
finances are on on an unsustainable path
and the uk could soon be tipped into uh
recession our economics and data editor
ed conway has this assessment of the
scale of the challenge facing whoever
becomes the next prime minister
so now we have more of a sense of what's
going on with the politics but what
about the economics well here there's a
couple of things to look at first of all
how do people view the uk uh as an
investment now you can get a sense of
that by looking at what's going on in
currency markets remember during brexit
how it was kind of going around up and
down depending on what was going on with
that roller coaster well here the funny
thing is it was moderately stable in the
last few days really weak the pound
right now against most other currencies
but it didn't seem to be moving until we
got that news that boris johnson was
going to resign when that news broke
just look at what happened to sterling
against the dollar it shot up and now it
is a fair bit stronger than it was
before so there's a bit of kind of
stability premium there people relieved
that we know a little bit more about
what's going to happen now but of course
the big question is what are they going
to do about economic policy what can
they do and one of the big things they
want to address is this both the
chancellor new chancellor anthony boris
johnson have talked a lot about the tax
burden and the fact that it is getting
up to the highest level that we've seen
since the 1940s that's the rate at which
we pay tax basically as a percentage of
gdp and look at how high that's going up
but here's the issue they want to cut
that but for some people the pressure
might be in the other direction the
office for budget responsibility they're
the people the government's kind of
official forecasters they produced this
bit of analysis just now looking at the
change in long-term deficit as a result
of things happening recently so
basically the higher these bars are the
more the deficit is going to go up you
can see the fiscal position actually
that's improved a bit recently but look
over to the other side so demography's a
bit worse so fewer people being born so
less people to to pay taxes net zero the
cost of net zero means that fewer taxes
are coming in petrol taxes and then
you've got social care and other factors
as well and you stack all of that up and
you're talking about quite a lot of
extra costs in fact
about 37 billion pounds worth if you
wanted to get net debt so the total
national debt down to the levels it was
before the pandemic you need to raise
taxes by 37 billion pounds not cut them
and that is a lot so that's one concern
uh for the prime minister leaving aside
whether he's actually able to pass any
of his legislation
but overshadowing everything is this
inflation this shows you the inflation
rate across the g7 so major economies
around the world everyone thought that
we had tamed it that it was going to be
low forever and look at what happened it
has risen to the highest level that
we've seen since the early 1980s and the
uk that red line
is the highest of all so it's that cost
of living crisis that is going to remain
the big economic challenge in the next
few months
ed conway there this is johnson resigns
a newshour special live from downing
street coming up
boris johnson resigns but he's not gone
yet i'll be talking to the conservative
mp teresa villiers next
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatched woods going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover before you
die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
we've been crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked where we're right
well enormous explosion has just come
down i think it was a monster just
landed in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
on sky news we discuss and debate the
issues that affect us in a new lineup of
midweek programmes at 9pm join me trevor
phillips for common ground where i bring
two people together who hold different
opinions on current topics seeing what
might unite them i'm sophie ridge join
me for the take where we'll be
discussing the biggest political stories
of the week getting the opinions from
politicians and also our viewers panel
and join me for beth rigby interviews as
i question decision makers from all
walks of life exploring their views on
what's going on with britain today join
us midweek at nine on sky news as we put
people at the heart of the stories
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
welcome back to downing street so boris
johnson and his new top team are
attempting to carry on as though it's
business as usual but is that
sustainable let's ask the conservative
mp teresa villiers thank you very much
for joining us and i see you join the
push for him to go only today so
you must have seen the writing on the
wall
it it just did seem impossible for the
prime minister to stay and post when
he'd lost the confidence of so many of
his ministers
um and i think it was just inevitable
that
he had to bring an end to
to this trauma that the government has
been going through so he made the right
decision to stand down today
many are unhappy that he hasn't gone
all together and handed over to a
caretaker
prime minister where do you stand on
that
what is proposed with him staying on
until a successor
is
chosen
is in line with what happened in
relation to david cameron and theresa
may
i don't see a practical alternative and
there is important government business
that must continue and will continue
so i think it's it's pragmatic
for boris and his team to stay in post
i mean the the point being made by john
major is that this if you can't
command the confidence of the house of
commons you shouldn't be here in downing
street
clearly you know big policy
announcements changes of direction none
of that is going to be possible it would
be
entirely inappropriate when when that
trust has been undermined in the way
that it has but there are for example
important items of legislation like the
northern ireland protocol bill which is
in in
progress through parliament we need
ministers to oversee that
you know there are important issues that
can still be dealt with even by an
interim caretaker prime minister and a
caretaker cabinet
isn't the problem that the country will
look at the conservative party over the
last few days
and simply conclude that it's chaos
this episode
has been
immensely damaging
for the conservatives and and the
government i i can't deny that we had a
terrible set of election results
followed by
a even more shocking set of by-election
results that demonstrated that
you know much of the electorate did want
to change at the top so i think that
from that point we need to work to
rebuild trust and make sure that whoever
takes over has a good strong coherent
plan to grow the economy help people
with the cost of living and get their
taxes down
so you concede that in staying on in the
way he has that it has inflicted damage
on the tory party
events of
you know recent weeks
there there has been significant
damage um
and that has to be repaired now
um i believe it can be we've got some
immensely talented people who i'm sure
will be
running for the leadership uh we have
two years potentially until the general
election there is lots that we as a
government can deliver for people um as
i say you know the key challenge is to
grow the economy
so that we can raise living standards
and tackle this inflation crisis
right now there's going to be a fight
clearly now for uh the leadership um all
sorts of people putting their
names forward um how do you think that
will play out who is who do you support
i've learned from experience
of these contests that it's wise to wait
for all the candidates to declare and
then
see each of them and and discuss with
them
what their plan is what they want to
achieve so
i have an open mind
and but i'm i'm certain that at the end
of the process we will have an excellent
new prime minister
all right if you won't say who you will
support or you haven't decided who you
will support who do you think the party
um will go for in the end
well that that is very hard to say i
mean there's obviously strong contenders
like like liz trust like rushy sonic
like zuella bravaman as well has
indicated that she wants to to run tom
toucanhart
it's it's gonna it's a big field for the
moment
and
i'm afraid i
i i'm not able to predict who is the
likely winner the person who looks the
the favorite at the start
very often isn't the winner at the end
no that is uh true let's just talk uh a
little bit more about boris johnson um
how
do you think he should be remembered as
prime minister
i believe he should be remembered for
keeping his promise to get brexit done
for securing
you know the biggest most extensive free
trade agreement that the eu has ever
signed up to
uh for for guiding us out of the
pandemic by with the fastest vaccine
delivery anywhere in europe
and for
leading the international response
against russian aggression in ukraine
and to add to that as london mayor he
delivered a phenomenally successful
olympic games so
there is a lot to remember that's
positive about boris johnson's time in
elected office
but uh do you think in hindsight he was
a risky choice um and that
people knew about his
his character they knew about the flaws
in that character
well when you're choosing any leader
there are uncertainties you don't know
how things will turn out there is there
is risk in every instance but
he did deliver
brexit as he promised he did deliver
election victory as well
and and as i've said there are
significant achievements during his
premiership it
despite you know the
you know the
very negative circumstances of of recent
weeks and and partygate there is still
much to be positive about in terms of
what he's delivered as prime minister
okay
okay
teresa teresa villas thank you very much
indeed
thank you
this is the news hour at six live from
downing street i'm mark austin coming up
in the next 60 minutes
a polarizing prime minister right to the
end the pugnacious boris johnson finally
admits
it's over
it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister
with his wife a daughter loyal aides and
mps watching he applauds his
achievements and addresses his
supporters
i want you to know how sad i am to be
giving up
the best job in the world
that them's the breaks
[Applause]
so boris johnson will go but he says not
yet pledging to wait until a successor
is chosen
the next leader might not be in position
until the autumn and the opposition say
they'll look to force the prime minister
out if he doesn't go sooner
if they don't get rid of him then labour
will step up in the national interest
and bring a vote of no confidence
because we can't go on with this prime
minister clinging on for months
and the impact and the legacy as
politician and prime minister from that
red bus
to get brexit dust strength
[Music]
good evening then from downing street
the scene today of a political drama
that will live long in the memory boris
johnson has resigned but he hasn't gone
in office but now a lame duck a prime
minister seeing out the dying days of
his premiership